- Vous savez, nous,
avec le gouvernement péquiste,
après ça le gouvernement
libéral, puis là,
le gouvernement caquiste,
puis on est encore en train
Fait qu'on se fait pas trop
d'illusions, là.
- Ces deux hommes sont membres
d'une coalition citoyenne fo
une coupe de bois dans l'une
des plus vieilles forêts
laurentiennes, celle du
mont Kaaikop, qui se trouve à
la limit
CLAUDE SAMSON, président, Coal.
pour préservation mont Kaaikop
- On arrive avec un dossier
étoffé, on a la population
de notre côté, je pense qu'a der
notre moratoire.
- La coalition obtient gain
en 2014 : la coupe de bois
n'aura pas lieu. Depuis,
le groupe réclame dument la prmn
permanente du Kaaikop,
de sa biodiversité
et des très vieusouvent bicente,
qui recouvrent 60 % du massi% d.
- C'est ce que tous
les scientifiques
pour lutter contre la crise
climatiqfondrement,
il faut protéger 30 % de notre
territoi
Il faut protéger des territoires
qui sonthes
en biodiversité, puis c'en est
un, ça. c'en est uété oublié da.
- Il faut rappeler que le Québec
est encore bien en deçà
de son objectif de protectiotren
des Laurentides. Pourtant,
à Québec, la demande de
la coalition est au point mort.
vous enfoncez depuis maintenant,
quoi, 10 ans?
- Oui, presque 11 ans, oui.
arrivé, depuis ce temps-là?
SERGE HA-président
Coal. préservation mont Kaaikop
- Bien, en fait, c'est
toujours. On voit le mont
comme une montagne
ordinaire, comme toutes
les autres montagnes qu'il y a,
C'est là, le problème.
- Les membres de ln
estiment que le Kaaikop est un
bijou de diversité biologique.
de forêt publique, une zone
qu'il faut protéger, disent-ils,
parce qu'elle a fait l'objet de
nombreuses coupes dans le passé
et qu'elle est auj
ANDRÉ GOULET, ingénieur forest.,
des terri des terri des terri s
- On a besoin de vieilles
forêts. Les vieilles forêts
20 et 40 % de plus d'espèces,
donc, et puis quand on sait
qu'il y a peut-être 50 %
des espèces qui sont encore
méconnuemonde, le monde, le mone
de précaution s'applique.- Depun
a pourtant pris les bouchées
doubles : des études sur
économique de la montagne,
une évalson potentson potentsonl
récréotouristique et des fonds
de 250 000 $ consacrés
- Il y a beaucoup de gens qui
appuient la coalitaaaaaaa
des professionnels qui appuient
la coalition, il y a
tuellement le sommet
du mont Kaaikop actuellement.
Donc ça, ça envoie
un message que ce n'est plus
nécessairement le chantierme,
mais l'idée de couper le bois
ou de gérêts
tel qu'on le fait aujourd'hui.
- Le groupe a également obtenu
le soutien d'une douzaine
FRÉDÉRIC BROUÉ,
maire de Sainte-Agathe-des-M
- Nous, à Sainte-Agathe,
on y croit énormément,
comme le mont Kaaikop,
c'est primordial pourl'environn.
FRANCIS CORBEIL, maire
de Sainte-Lucie-des-Laurenti
quelque chose, on dirait,
que persabituéabituéabituéabitué
de travailler, puis c'est
compliqué avec tout le monde.mad
jusqu'à la bonne personne?
Je ne suis pas certain.
- La coalition confirme :
à Québec, la port
Pendant toutes ces années-là,
s êtes assis à plusieurs
reprises avec le gouvernement?
- C'est le ministère des Forêts,
pour les coupes forestières.
Puis lui, son mand
le disent au gouvernement,
c'est de couper, d'envoyer faire
ources naturelles est
passé, il a donné les droitsde t
le martelage. Lui, il est là
pour faire bûcher, fait qu'
♪ ♪ ♪
- La question qui se pose
maintenant est la suivante,
10 ans d'efforts, ils sont
encore id'obtenir
la protection d'à peine 40 km
de forêt dans une région qui en?
intergénérationnel qu'on veut
faire avlà,
les anciens en ont profité.
Elle est encore intacte. ça ques
en profitent également.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Le projet d'aire protégéeKaaie
un quarantième de la superficie
du parc du Mont-Tremblant.
Radio-Canada,
Laurentide